[The camera pans across the construction site of the planned National Institutes of Health Clinical Center, building 10.]
[Cars, trucks, and workers come into view.]
[A temporary wooden walkway is shown.]
[Workers move about in the excavated area.]
[Temporary plywood support walls are being erected at the perimeter of the pit.]
[Workmen carry lumber, hammer nails, drive earth-moving equipment, and walk around the work site.]
[A LeTourneau motor scraper comes into view.]
[Part of the foundation has been prepared. Forms are in place for the pouring of concrete.]
[A man carries a piece of lumber on his shoulder.]
[About a dozen workers are atop the wooden framing. A machine for pouring concrete into forms has been positioned.]
[The camera pans around the site showing mounds of earth, storage sheds, heavy equipment and 1940s-era automobiles.]
[Screen dark]
[Plywood support wall is shown with men working nearby in the excavated pit.]
[Work near the plywood wall continues.]
[Camera pans across the large site. Mounds of earth, framing, and temporary steps and ladders are shown.]
[Screen dark]
[Camera pans across the area.]
[A Caterpillar motor grader crosses the worksite.]
[Another piece of heavy equipment drives by.]
[Workers add a section to the plywood wall, building it higher.]
[Film ends]